On behalf of the propmasters who worked on
one of the greatest science fiction films
of all time: uhh… whoops?
Lucasfilm executive Pablo Hidalgo recently
took to Twitter to share an image which perhaps
constitutes, considering Star Wars' popularity,
one of the biggest goofs in the history of
cinema.
We'll put it this way: if you never knew that
the Skywalker clan originated in the Big Apple,
you're in for a surprise.
We know what you're thinking…
"I don't follow."
But bear with us.
In Hidalgo's tweet, the executive began by
noting his belief that the Star Wars flicks
offer something new to the audience upon every
viewing, an assessment that probably has more
to do with the series' diligent attention
to detail than it does boneheaded errors.
But upon his latest viewing of Empire, Hidalgo
had one small detail leap out at him like
a vicious Wampa defending its territory: the
etchings on the bottom of Luke Skywalker's
lightsaber.
Remember the iconic scene in which the budding
Jedi uses the Force to summon his weapon and
free himself from his icy, upside-down imprisonment?
It's pretty cool fantasy stuff, right?
But it turns out, this moment is much more
grounded in reality than you might expect.
Hidalgo wrote,
"I've noted this before, but every time I
watch a Star Wars movie, there's something
new to notice.
Especially if I'm fortunate to catch it on
the big screen.
This latest discovery? that 'NEW YORK' is
visible on the bottom of Luke's lightsaber
in EMPIRE."
It certainly seems like a heck of an oversight
on the part of the props department.
So how did it happen?
In standard theatrical screenings, the markings
would have been barely legible to the audience.
But The Empire Strikes Back was a hotly anticipated
sequel to the single most pop culture-dominating,
visual effects-driven blockbuster the world
had ever seen.
As a result, it enjoyed a profitable run in
theaters in the high-definition 70mm format,
which makes the markings much more visible.
Still, it seems no one noticed or made note
of the goof until 2019.
How could it be that out of thousands of fans,
viewing this scene in the highest resolution
available, not one of them noticed that Luke's
lightsaber was apparently manufactured in
New York?
For that matter, we'll do you one better.
Empire has been available on Blu-Ray for years,
a release which boasts pristine resolution
and has sold tons of copies - probably literally.
And still, no one noticed the error.
Many Star Wars aficionados consider The Empire
Strikes Back to be the undisputed high point
of the entire series; there are probably some
fans who have watched this movie more times
than the sum total of every movie you have
ever seen.
So the fact that this blatant mistake has
escaped the attention of one of the most dedicated
and rabid fan bases on the planet for almost
four decades is, quite simply, mind-boggling.
"Are your minds blown?"
Hidalgo engaged in a lively exchange with
fans in the wake of his post, many of whom
were quick to point out that while the error
was indeed visible, it wasn't exactly legible.
Hidalgo responded,
"On the big screen it can be seen; though
of course, it took about 40 years for me to
notice."
Hidalgo also pointed fans who may be interested
in a deep dive into the Star Wars series'
props toward a website, partsofsw.com, that
features a nifty compendium of all of the
common, everyday objects which were used to
bring the series' world to life.
In the tweet in question, Hidalgo referred
to many of Star Wars' props as being, quote,
"eco-friendly."
From looking at the collection of recycled
gun parts, tape, and old TV equipment, it
seems like "eco-friendly" could just be a
synonym for"cheap."
This serves as an intriguing reminder that,
for all their unprecedented scale, the original
Star Wars trilogy was completely unafraid
to employ guerrilla filmmaking techniques
in service of its galaxy-spanning vision.
That's pretty rad, if you ask us.
On another wholesome note, when you think
about it, it's actually a testament to the
skill of the filmmakers that the enormous
worldwide audience for The Empire Strikes
Back was so utterly sucked into its world
that every last one of them failed to catch
this glaring detail for so long.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.